and we got the Dow cross in that 20,000
level the down now sitting at 20,000
19-point 46 up 106 points five tenths of
one percent we've been knocking on the
twenty-thousand-dollar door for many
days we got very close a few weeks ago
but could not breach that level we have
now done it you have industrials
financials helping to claw the dow
higher to break that level yes of course
in theory what does down 20k really mean
but for a lot of day traders
particularly my mom at home that number
might mean something this is a look at
the dow jones industrial average over
the last year last few months i should
say up by a five percent now it took
about sixty four days for the dow to get
from 19,000 to 20,000 but that's only a
five point three percent move when the
dow went from 10,000 to 11,000 that was
35 days but at ten percent moves you
have to kind of take this rally in this
velocity in with a little bit of stride
stripping it back a little bit did want
to take a look at some of the individual
movers as the SPO i should point out hit
another record high this morning we have
some action in the bank stocks here
you've got state street off by five
percent JPMorgan up by one percent a
black rock is going to move one trillion
dollars from state street to JPMorgan as
they move to lower costs for clients JP
Morgan has about twenty point five
trillion dollars in custody currently
State Street has over twenty eight
trillion so a move there for Blackrock
so that's having an impact on some of
these bank stocks but going forward
we're looking at those cyclical stocks
John that continue to move higher the
question now is is this based on hope
and optimism and when does that run out